[Musique]
[Rires]
au milieu des rues du cap en afrique du
sud deux réunionnais se balade dans les
quartiers branchés depuis un an
valerian et nelson vivent en afrique du
sud annonce suit c'est la rue qui est
connu pour ses bars et ses boîtes de
nuit ses restaurants c'est la rue de la
nuit au cap
on arrêtait on n'avait rien à perdre à
postuler dans le cadre de ce programme
là parce que j'étais au chômage depuis
deux ou trois ans je vais préparer les
concours de la fonction publique
j'avais vraiment envie de revenir ici on
a fait du sud c'est un pays que je
connais c'est et et que je j'avais
vraiment adoré et et voilà pour moi
c'était aussi une opportunité de devenir
pro à améliorer mon anglais
ce jour là des élus du département sont
en mission de coopération dans ce pays
arc-en-ciel sacrée expérience
professionnelle dans un domaine non
seulement culturel mais aussi
au niveau 2
des missions qui nous sont dévolues à
savoir la promotion du français
et voilà travailler dans ce cadre là et
être en contact avec des locaux au
quotidien je pense que ça c'est
l'alliance dans ce cadre et une
ouverture vers le monde extérieur dans
cette association relais de la culture
française la réunion est très présente
j'étais extrêmement bien accueilli par
le directeur de l'alliance et mon
prédécesseur à l'époque
le cadre m'a tout de suite plu j'ai aimé
où j'étais logé et c'est dès le
lendemain mon arrivée je me suis mis à
travailler
donc au début ça a été un peu
catastrophique parce que je comprenais
rien l'accent ces africains c'était un
peu un peu particulier et et puis avec
le temps en fait dont ça a été en fait
on maintenant ça va beaucoup mieux deux
petites îles ou de saint denis c'est
d'abord une expérience qu'ils sont venus
chercher au cap
j'ai peut-être 45 ans mais je peux
sortir de ma zone de confort que j'ai
voyagé avant j'ai fait pas mal de choses
qui me permettent justement de d'avoir
une approche complètement différente et
du travail et de la vie aussi donc
donc je peux être plus en plus finement
et en même temps savoir réagir quand ils
le font donc la série c'est très utile
pour pour ce programme de coopération
parce que clairement c'est des postes
très importants en alliance que
l'alliance elle même n'aurait pas
forcément les moyens de le financer
et cette aide là et précieuse donc pour
pour l'alliance donc c'est un bon mode
de fonctionnement
ici le travail ne manque pas cours de
langue organisation d'événements chaque
instant est une expérience de plus son
vassal terrain que que ça marche que
l'assertion que l'on promeut va chez les
jeunes
au sein du département marche et que ça
sert à quelque chose
oui effectivement il faut sauter la mer
en est à 4 heures de la réunion
c'est vraiment un pays à découvrir c'est
un pays qui a aussi de l'avenir
certainement pas même si un taux de
chômage encore important en afrique du
sud il y à il ya de l'activité et on
voit que c'est un pays qui bouge
[Musique]
une auto dans ce que je perçois c'est
qu'il ya parfois des tensions encore la
réunion et jeudi on a la chance pourtant
depuis l'an 2000 qui est sorti vers qui
est belle pion qui est belle à la fois
par sa géographie et puis par sa
richesse historique aussi enfin le
métissage douce à la rencontre des
peuples même si ça s'est fait dans la
violence mais aujourd'hui chaque année
le département propose près d'une
centaine de contrats uniques d'insertion
en afrique du sud et dans les autres
pays de l'océan à dire j'aurais été
reconnaissante d'avoir pu participer et
je retiendrai toutes les rencontres que
j'aurais fait ici et qui m'ont fait
grandir
que ça soit humainement
professionnellement j'ai vraiment
là l'occasion de respirer de penser
autrement d'agir différemment donc jeu
juste dans le plongeon de ce que j'étais
auparavant mais en mieux
en fait pour mettre un baume est
ensemble on met ensemble
[Musique]